I never done it hi there I'm Arya we're
here in very very sunny Los Angeles and
today I'm gonna purchase something off
of the dark web it's a good way to spend
a tuesday huh so Wednesday
what's once last year we did an
investigation into the dark web so the
reason why I want to buy something off
the dark web is twofold firstly pretty
cool but coolest item to knock off and B
I actually want to see what legal Goods
can be purchased on the dark web ok so
last time I went on the dark web I
gotten a little bit of trouble with our
IT department for using my work computer
as well as the BuzzFeed Network to get
online so this time they're insisting
that I get a burner laptop before I
purchase anything off the dark web so
let's go do that first we don't know the
password to the burner nor save your
time we're into some extra stuff ah
there's extra schinsky a multiplayer huh
dark web stuff dark web stuff that's how
bad you know you know it's a little
early for a wedding gift no no I'm gonna
get whatever you know you need this zach
is engaged to beautiful women kdl harper
that's our yeah it's al Stanford Lori
Lorraine I'm buy something at the dark
web yes yes she has a date tonight lucky
maybe fingers crossed
that's good
so the password is what okay
ah there's Devon Title I purchasing
something off of the dark web oh Jesus
hugging that man luckily my dark web
expert Jake is still around so we're
gonna hit him up and hopefully he can
help navigate me through purchasing
something off of the dark web all right
Jake
America back on the dark web one year
later unfortunately we can't buy
anything illegal although that would be
a lot more fun but obviously if we
bought ourselves several pounds of coke
and had it shipped to BuzzFeed that
might not might not look too good HR I
already have quite a file on me so let's
look literally so we can't buy uncut
Colombian fish-scale cocaine so the
struggle for us right now is using
marketplaces known for selling illegal
goods to try and find something legal
we've been here before us we've got
dissociative we've got stimulants I
don't even know what you're some of you
somebody's sound like k-pop groups 5ma
oh yeah it's kind of like a baby stolen
pictures there's a lot of nudity yeah
that's unfortunate viagra you know what
the meat I'm gonna call our legal rep
see if we can buy some viagra by egg
because viagra viagra is legal right I'm
pretty sure it's prescription but it's
legal to use but if you don't have a
prescription you can't buy it's a little
double-check and ask hey Adam I just
wanted to see if I could buy some viagra
give me a call back when you have the
chance
counterfeits also hack one of our
colleagues yes that's a great gift there
several colleagues that I wouldn't mind
getting hacked here I don't actually
wanna do that I might Outlook new
Instagram followers real 1,000
high-quality a lot of influencers here
at BuzzFeed that might be interested in
this the only thing about that is this
guy only has one review and he has zero
stars I mean for six for six dollars I'm
willing to give this guy a try we're
gonna give the followers - what do you
wanna do it on because they're gonna get
your name
information link to your profile well
I'm not doing this through my my
personal okay well I just need your
Instagram handle so yeah my wife and I
have a noise ban that we have a
currently 110 followers so uh submit a
cool one time give me what that was what
that was in 100 intent this is
interesting to me that they sell harm
reduction hearing like needles test kits
so we could get something off of that
that would be something legal we could
buy yeah cash out
hacking IDs pass prepare for nail you
haven't done that good yeah check out
other there too we've been here over
almost now and a half now took us some
time but we managed to just plow through
all the illegal goods to find a few
legal goods we could purchase so so way
more porn than I wanted to see today
just about the right amount I wanted a
how does this process work basically we
have to go on we're gonna have to buy
cryptocurrency we're gonna have to
transfer it to a wallet and secure
wallet after we transfer it to that
wallet you're gonna send your money to
the escrow service escrow service is
gonna hold it confirm they have the
money with the vendor when the vendor
gets the confirmation they have the
money they send the goods and then when
you confirm you get the goods the escrow
service releases the money if you don't
get the goods that you're buying you can
do the review so you review the vendor
you can actually see people who have
been ripped off and then those vendors
usually will get booted off these
marketplaces too it's about as
sophisticated as a regular marketplace
just for illegal goods I have a feelings
it's gonna take a little bit yeah that's
good do your thing Jake while Jake is
currently in the process of purchasing
our goods off of the dark web I'll take
this moment right now to address one of
the points of confusion from our last
video there are a lot of comments along
the lines of oh now that you've visited
the dark web you should visit the Deep
Web with the implication of course that
the Deep Web is darker than the dark web
this is false
so if you think of the Internet as an
iceberg of sorts everything we do on a
day to day basis on YouTube or Facebook
or Google this can be considered the
clear web but Neath the surface of the
water though is then the Deep Web the
Deep Web refers to pages that aren't
indexed by search engines like Google so
this can mean pages that are behind a
paywall or that require a special login
or something along those lines but these
pages can still be accessed on regular
browsers like Chrome or Firefox or
Safari if for some reason you use Safari
but then beneath the Deep Web is the
dark web and the
dark where refers to sites and pages
that you can't access through normal
browsers but only through special
routing software like tor so that was my
quick crash course as to what the
difference between the clear web the
deep web and the dark web actually is so
now Jake is just gonna finish up the
purchases and we'll just wait till our
goods get here and we're on track uh we
have the Bitcoin this is the first time
I've ever purchased anything on dark web
or we purchase something on the dark web
it's actually a lot easier than I
thought it was gonna be - all right I'm
doing it I'll buy it
there's been about 17 days since we
placed the order and this is the only
thing I found my mailbox this what a
package from the dark web looks like
very standard fare
we ordered actually a few more things
that actually aren't here this is also
on top of the fact that we ordered fake
Instagram followers for Dan Watkins we
bought a thousand followers for his
Instagram account and we were promised
24-hour turnaround it's been over 15 16
days and he still has the same amount of
followers so I got you a bad review but
I feel a few things in here so we
ordered a few items from the same seller
and so I think we got a couple a couple
of goodies in here and I'm excited to
open them
Jake unfortunate couldn't be here today
to do the unboxing with us since Jake's
not here I thought I'd be a bit fun to
share this dark web joy with a few of my
coworkers so let's see what they think
about these items
I
hi own learning heaven Joyce and God
yell two beautiful people accomplices
truth actually no my name is Jerome yeah
Jerome Garcia to our friend Fernando
which is weird I shoved it to my address
by used his name what's worse case
scenario what's in there what are you
most afraid I keep imagining body parts
nothing it's obviously not that I feel
like it's like a travel bag made of the
scrotum of some kind of animal
okay specific okay make it I'll let you
do the first cameras rolling you know as
the people not to do this for drugs just
to pick a lock there's a mirror oh my
does have been razor it's for drugs is
to smoke crack
it is a cocaine kid okay
oh my god it's to scoop it what oh yeah
oh that's fun your reaction so different
to Joseph I just like this tiny spoon is
this what you keep poking yes I would
assume so and it has like a hook so you
keep it on your pants clean I'm sure
it's clean know that what the hell is
that Saran sir mother cooking how badly
do you want to cocaine on the shoot what
is this what is this is that another no
no there are no drugs cocaine
there's no cocaine here we'll fight
right now what is oh my god this is just
a murderer
then we have this Oh is it just for
sniffing or a minim honker
no wait the coca gonna be in here does
it right though we'll try our isn't
wanting to try this drug for very long I
have not enough he ordered a starters
kit so apart from just the physical
items you buy electronic out it's a Jake
he bought like ebooks that are like
scans of restricted texts so these texts
are not legal they're they're legal
there is hard to find they're hard if I
can get them in a bookstore then some of
them are like voodoo and dark magic I
did not call you here for that reason
magic from Mexico include some spells
incantations now look this one's for
love here oh I need that one this how
this is happening you cast a love spell
on you yeah would you like to I think
you should cast the spell okay say for
myself little tip for yourself Megan
ladies and gentlemen out there that
would love a wonderfully talented caring
beautiful woman at Megan boy coughs yes
okay she has her own drug kit give me
what I desire Porto poder o Valentin
bendito a Ming Amen
oh how you feeling you feel something
well they how will I know if that worked
oh you see the lights of candles for job
summer oil I meant to pick a an oriental
master I have that I got a young man for
each other
this is what I do it these are my
friends this is what they want to do on
a Monday morning
lunch Jake also ordered 16,000 dark web
links which are links to more sites that
are deeper in the dark web so you have
here Bitcoin wallet diamonds on Donna's
it's the messaging drugs cheap drugs
pedo videos oh no yeah so this is how
pedophiles still get there they see that
ways that child porn or something
Wow my body is physically nervous sorry
I'm sorry we'll stop talking about that
but it is really really upsetting I feel
like it kind of shows you the underbelly
of society that you don't necessarily
want to see and it's unfortunate that
these things like pedo pornography are
available because that means some kid
somewheres anyway it's awful I have no
problem people buying you know their
weed I think the dark web is probably a
really cool and interesting place and
you can find great things that are
positive but like everything in life
there's a lot of negatives it's just the
idea that that's available and it has
access to people and children are
getting hurt like that's the part of the
dark web when I think of that that's
what anyone's talked about that is that
those links cost $10 for $10 you can
watch this this worse though when we
were browsing the dark web last time we
only saw surface level stuff you know
we've saw drugs we saw some weapons some
fraud but we didn't see sites like pedo
sites and the fact that yeah you can pay
$10 or so for these links what about the
stuff that's not readily available to be
purchased as human beings we could be
very horrible people this and so I could
imagine something like this how far
people willing to go this was a good way
to dip my toes in if any of you out
there were like to see me dive even
deeper in the dark web let me know
the links are what scared me more than
the witchcraft please stop going on the
dark web please what a time so do I need
a special a special like I need a
download something special I'll send it
yeah yeah I'll send you as a browser
special browser cardio house I'm gonna
bring a machete
I'm gonna put this to your neck are you
going I'm just going it dark web around
me absolutely not